well an exclusive Poll for Sky News
carried out by yougov suggests the
public support for trade unions is
growing our business correspondent
gurpreet narwan is with me this is
intriguing what uh more can you tell us
about the day it's interesting isn't it
because you might be tempted to think as
these strikes rumble on as more and more
services are disrupted that the public
would start to lose the patience with it
but the opposite is happening this
exclusive polling commission by Sky News
shows that support for unions is
actually growing
um if we show the first
um the first chart here we can see that
37 of those surveyed now think that
unions play a positive role in society
that's up from 35 back in November well
just 28 say they play a negative role in
society which suggests that the
government which has been refusing to
budge on those inflation matched pay
Rises won't necessarily be able to rely
on waning support right and is it the
same story across the you know the piece
across the entire public sector it's
probably not a surprise that support for
unions has risen just as the industrial
action has spread uh to the NHS we can
see here that nurses and ambulance staff
are at the top top this poll they
consistently get the most support from
the public and like large swathes of the
public sector they've endured real terms
pay cuts over the last decade nurses
have seen their pay Fall by seven
percent over the last 10 years at the
bottom we've got University staff
traditionally better paid but probably
worth pointing out that University
lecturers have endured a 17.5 real terms
pay cut over the last decade right and
now there is this strike legislation
being debated in uh the commons with
minimum service provision what does the
public think of that yeah I mean the
takeaway from all of this so far is that
support for unions is rising but it's
all very finally balanced because when
we ask the public what they think about
how easy it is for trade unions to go on
strike they said a large chunk of them a
third said that it's far too easy for
unions to go on strike and it needs to
be made more difficult just a fifth said
it should be made easier so in one
respect support for unions is growing
but it's still very much a contentious
issue yeah okay good pretty interesting
stuff thanks very much indeed